last night it was round two of the
Republican presidential debate and many
of the presidential hopefuls were
outspoken about Iran and foreign policy
we don't get along with China we don't
get along with the heads of Mexico we
don't get along with anybody and yet at
the same time they rip us left and right
they take advantage of us economically
in every other way if I am elected
president on the very first day in
office I will rip to shreds this
catastrophic Iranian nuclear deal should
we cut up the agreement immediately
that's absurd when you want to know if
they've complied with us now from our
Washington bureaus Bloomberg's world
affairs contributor and us former
defense secretary william cohen bill
thank you so much for joining us this
morning what was your take on the
presidential candidates foreign policy
views last night who do you think was
right on the Iran issue well first they
all deserve credit for standing there
for three hours without a break but
secondly I think you must be careful
what you pledge during any campaign I've
always tried to give advice a be careful
what you promise during a campaign
because number two if you successful you
may have to break the pledge and then
you undermine your own credibility I
think it is wise on the part of those to
say I'm going to think about it very
seriously the first day I'm in office as
to whether I want to take the risk of
tearing something up without consulting
with allies Without Really plumbing the
depths of what this would mean in terms
of the consequences so I think it's one
thing to promise I'll tear it up it's
another thing to say what happens if you
do tear it up what are the consequences
for the United States and our allies I
think they're caution is it's better be
pursued by the candidates rather than
any kind of a bomb best or absolute
ironclad cement cemented pledge to was
and tear it up I think it's a mistake to
do that so I'd say those who urged some
caution on it were the
in my judgment with the winners all
right so Rand Paul seemed to be the only
one on stage urging caution and he said
he wants to keep to the agreement at
least for the time being because he
wants to check to make sure that Iran is
complying with the agreement is this the
kind of thing where we'll be able to
know if they're complying each and every
day or in the first week or first months
I mean isn't a compliance something that
needs to be checked years after the
agreement that is one of the challenges
it was not only Rand Paul I believe that
Jeb Bush also urged some caution as to
John Kasich that they would look at it
very carefully before they would make a
decision as to whether to tear this up
but yes I think initially there will be
an effort on the part of Iran assuming
that it votes to confirm this deal and
that is something is now being debated
within Iran itself but assuming that it
goes forward with this agreement I think
we have to be very careful in the
beginning they're likely to comply as
time goes on the compliance will be less
intense on their part and they may seek
to circumvent it so it's going to
require more intensive effort on the
part of the international inspectors and
that's going to be tough to sustain and
that's why I think the focus ought to be
at this particular point what can we do
now to really shore up the capability of
Saudi Arabia UAE Qatar and the others
especially Israel to make sure that they
are much more secure than they are today
to prevent Iran from using their new
power to present a threat to them so I
think the focus has to be on the
inspections but also what we can do
right now to bolster the capability of
those Gulf states and israel in the
region bill what do you think that of
lindsey graham in the first debate
arguing for a build-up Carly Fiorina and
the second debate arguing for a
significant military buildup have we let
our defense forces down well let me say
this i think it's embarrassing that this
country would be faced with another
government shutdown that sends a signal
to the world that we're not a serious
country
to the extent that we would once again
shut the government of the United States
down doesn't send a signal of strength
or that we're providing leadership
number one number two I think Congress
it's embarrassing that Congress doesn't
have a budget so all of this talk about
we're going to do this with Iran we're
going to confront China we're going to
confront Russia they take a look at your
budget you're going from resolution to
resolution and you really can't plan for
building a strong military unless you
have an agreement up on the hill so I
think there's an embarrassment there
that we don't have a budget and we don't
have really a consensus on the way
forward and that's something that other
countries are looking at they're making
their own assessments of us leadership
when us the US Congress can't reach an
agreement on what needs to be funded
especially our military capability
especially our state Department
especially those programs dealing with
the health and security the people of
this country if we can't agree on that
then we're not gonna be very successful
in having a strong foreign policy
because it won't have the wherewithal to
enforce any kind of strategy that we
have got it thanks very much for that
bill Bloomberg's world affairs
contributor and former defense secretary
bill Cohen